[Music]
that's why
i love dirt roads is off granger smith's
tenth studio album aptly named
country things volume one it's the first
project from the texan native
who stepped away from the spotlight last
year after the tragic loss of his
three-year-old son
river now granger along with his wife
and their two other children are sharing
their emotional journey with their fans
in their youtube series called the
smiths and granger tells cheryl that as
difficult as it is for him to open up it
is
helping the family heal i want to thank
you for being so
open there are so many families who um
sadly have been in your position
what is the response been from fans and
even people who are
are new to your series we started the
channel
before our tragedy and so people
they took the journey with us in a lot
of ways we just wanted to
come on here and talk to you guys and
just let you know that we're seeing all
of your comments and we're getting all
of your letters
and we're receiving the outpouring of
love that you guys have given us these
past couple weeks and we just wanted to
say thank you
and kind of let you know how we're doing
it was difficult at times
i closed the smith channel down for
probably three months
and didn't do anything but then when i
opened it back up
it truly became a point of healing a a
vessel for us to to take out into
unknown waters and to
to show people what um what the next
step looks like what the next breath
looks like
i think the platform that we're that we
that we immediately stand
for is love those
close to you soak up those moments
you say hi everybody hi welcome to the
smiths
a lot of people have have gone through
maybe not something specifically like us
but some kind of loss knowing that if we
did that that would also help us
in our own process besides finding
solace
in their youtube series granger has also
turned to music
completing work on his album country
things volume one
you were in the process of writing and
creating this 10th studio album
and you stepped away as you said to to
mourn and to heal
what did you learn about yourself as a
as a person as a dad as an artist
during that time it was just really
focusing on
really honing in on the things that
matter
living in the present or being at least
being aware of the present moment that
tomorrow is not guaranteed
that we always get in this rat race of
especially the music business
the next album the next single the next
tour planning for the next
and less of concentrating on what we
have today
the blessing that today and the present
moment is to us
and i think that's what really happened
to me most is sharing your story
helped the healing process yeah it
really has um i would say probably more
so right now for my wife
she finds meaning and sharing
more openly about her feelings knowing
that
like you said there's people that could
then come forward and say
i i'm going through something similar
and now watching you do amber express
yourself
it's giving me hope